nbc this morning had a reporter go on
and literally give tips on how to deal
with inflation and one of the tips i
can't make this up one of the tips is
quote if you don't get a turkey fewer
people might come over and that would
save you more money also we literally
have the mainstream media suggesting
that rather than deal with inflation
from a monetary and fiscal policy
standpoint rather than report and say
the official numbers are over six
percent inflation the unofficial numbers
are double digits and literally
americans are suffering we have them
instead saying you want to deal with
inflation don't buy a turkey don't have
people come over don't live your life
you should sacrifice because the people
who are making these decisions they're
getting rich but you sit at home don't
get a turkey for thanksgiving this is
peak insanity peak clown world how about
instead we teach people it's not about
spending you are not going to save your
way
faster than inflation is going to eat
you you can not save when there's high
inflation you have to learn to invest
the message is not do not consume as
much as you were no the message instead
is you have to learn to invest and so to
see this on mainstream media it's not
only that it's absurd that they're
literally saying the best way to deal
with inflation is to not buy a turkey
pretty crazy but even worse is that it's
the wrong advice telling people to
essentially save not spend save more
save more save more
is actually the wrong thing to tell them
that's what your grandparents did that's
what your parents might have told you to
do but in today's society you have to
learn to invest so jojo i don't think
you guys saw this but i mean absolutely
nuts to see literally on nbc they said
thanksgiving cost there's things that
you could do like a potluck
or you could split the cost with others
or consider not buying a turkey
in order to combat inflation yeah the
the the nutritional advice of using
soybeans was uh the one that put it over
the top for me i don't think that uh
central banks or the government or
associated agencies should be giving out
nutritional advice to help save you
money uh when what they're doing in
response is just printing a bunch of
money and causing these prices of the
goods that you would normally to
increase and you not be able to afford
them uh outside of outside of wage
growth so i i it's kind of ridiculous
the narrative is is
has changed and a lot of people are
they're honestly squirming to try to
find like different ways to pitch it or
different uh segments around it or
whatever it is uh but it's pretty
embarrassing i you know the the
economist we talked about the other day
had a had a tweet or a headline that
said no one saw it coming no one saw
inflation coming and literally everyone
on the internet was like what are you
talking about like not only do you call
yourself the economist but you guys have
you been on the internet for the last
year and a half have you been on the
internet for two years like we literally
everyone has been talking about this for
a year and a half that this was going to
be coming after the unprecedented uh
stimulus and
and uh money printing that you guys did
over the last year year and a half and i
think it's kind of embarrassing that now
they're trying to give out nutritional
advice off the back of that so uh and i
don't think we're anywhere close to the
end of this stuff it's going to continue
right so turkey if you go buy it up 21
year over year it is more expensive that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't buy a
turkey this is absolutely ridiculous the
more and more that i read about uh read
what mainstream media is putting out to
the american people it's embarrassing to
be frank um this is exactly why we made
this show because we people need to hear
the absolute truth about what's going on
and not be told hey instead of buying a
turkey go use soybeans or go do
something else don't buy a turkey less
people will come over that's just not
the right message to send people